how many games of chess are there so
there is a popular fact that the number
of games of chess is greater for the
number of atoms there are in the
observable universe this is the fact is
it true well the number of games of
chess is known as Shannon's number so
let's find out what is Shannon's number
and how it was worked out called Shannon
he in the 1950s he wrote a paper how to
program a computer to play chess it was
about how to program a computer to play
chess and in that paper he came up with
an estimate for how many games of chess
there are so is only an estimate so he
estimated that the number of games of
chess would be 10 to the power around
about 10 to the power 120 well too
massive its billions and trillions of
google's it's so massive that's a huge
number if we compare that with atoms in
the observable universe there's about 10
to the 80 atoms in the observable
universe so there are more games of
chess you could assign billions of games
of chess for each atom in the universe
how did he come up with this massive
figure so what he decided was well he
looked at some games of chess and he
said well on average at any position
there are about thirty legal moves that
you can make so the first player would
have thirty legal moves he could make
and if you do two moves that's the first
player then the second player then that
would be for each move by the first
player the second player would have 30
so it was only two moves it'd be 30 by
30 so that'd be 900 already just with
two moves some terminology here when I'm
saying moves I actually mean what it's
called a ply and that means the plate
one player goes first then the second
player goes next then the next player so
in chess terminology a move
they're white player than the black
player so another move would be a white
player again the black player whole game
but we're just gonna say moves to be
each player takes and move it's actually
could apply in chess terminology so if
the first player has 30 legal moves he
can make then for each move the second
player has another 30 legal moves he can
make so with just two moves that are 900
moves you can make all together if it
was three moves it would be 30 by 30 by
30 if it was four moves you'd be 30 by
30 by 30 by 30 Shannon said well a game
is about 40 moves that was in chess
terminology so he means 80 plays so this
is all Shannon did he said a game is
about 30 legal moves 80 plays and that
is around about 10 to the 120
wishy-washy yeah it was only in passing
it was only an estimate it was only a
paragraph of the paper and he he did
this rough estimate this rough number to
show that if you had a computer and it
was trying to work out then the future
of the game and trying to work out all
the legal moves and where this game was
going to go so that he could make
decisions of how to play next then the
computer would never make a move it was
if it was calculating one game per
microsecond it would be until the end of
the universe it would never play this
was the point Shannon was trying to make
with his rough estimates so we're gonna
have a look at the sequence of games
there are when each player takes their
turn so the first move is by white so
let's take the first move and white has
20 legal moves so we've got we've got
one here for each pawn we've got so
that's eight we've got the double move
fair by each pointer we got 16 we've got
two moves there for each night
two moves on this side here and here and
that's 20 so 20 moves for the first
player now black takes the next turn and
for the next turn what he can respond
with the same 20 moves so for each move
player one takes black can take a twenty
move so you multiply its twenty by
twenty there are now 400 games that
could have happened already with just
two moves there are already 400 games
that could have happened let's see what
happens next then suddenly it becomes
much more complicated when white plays
next it becomes eight thousand nine
hundred and two moves shouldn't suddenly
pull eight thousand what nearly nine
thousand games that you can play with
just three plays this sounds a lot more
precise than what Shannon was doing this
is real numbers yeah these are real
numbers with these small numbers we can
work this out so far so good it's going
to get harder with larger numbers so
let's write out a few more the next move
is black and he'll have one hundred and
ninety seven thousand seven hundred and
forty two so after black moves again we
are now have one hundred and ninety
seven thousand seven hundred forty two
possible games that could have been
played all the possible games we could
have done in those four moves is already
two hundred thousand this is crazy huge
numbers already huge numbers though you
are able to know exactly what the number
is so it just seems like if you spend
enough time on this you'll be okay we
can keep going can we
so we can keep going and these numbers
are gonna get bigger and bigger now in
theory the total number the largest
number the longest chess game can be
something around eleven thousand eight
hundred of these plies eleven thousand
eight hundred and that's in invoking
there you have to invoke the 50 move
rule because you could just go on
forever if you just ended up with two
kings this game backwards and forth
gain could last forever so there is a
rule that stops a game lasting forever
that says well if you've played 50 moves
with nothing being captured and you're
just messing about that is yeah it's a
pawn hasn't moved something hasn't been
captured or you repeat the board three
times if that happens then you call it a
draw so there's a cut-off point now some
people have worked out what the longest
possible chess game is it's something
around eleven thousand eight hundred the
some disagreement not much disagreement
though within a hundred or so of that so
if you see how fast this sequence is
growing can you imagine how many games
there are all together especially when
you're going all the way up to what
nearly 12,000 moved some of those games
will be non cent games where you can win
you've only got one move left and you
can win in one move but you don't you
just start moving other pieces and you
start doing other things it becomes a
massively complex tree of possibilities
and that's why this number is just going
off to huge numbers Godfrey Hardy
a famous 20th century mathematician he
tried to estimate the number of chess
games that were his estimate was 10 to
the power at 10 to the power 50 to the
power of 50 let me say that again it was
10 to the power 10 to the power 50 this
this is minuscule when you compare it
with what a Hardys estimate was what
Shannon was doing was saying this is a
40 move game where the average number of
moves is 30 so he was saying that the if
there were 80 plays that's what he's
saying he's saying this is about 10 to
the power at 120 that's what Shannon is
saying so he's not even not considering
all these other games so it was Godfrey
Hardy at yet the famous 20th century
mathematician worked at Cambridge
discovered ram anujan he tried to
estimate how many games have chester
where it was actually when he was
writing about ram anujan because ram
anujan had sent him a paper which had a
large number in it he said just to
understand how big this number is if he
compared it to the number of games of
chess I reckon that's 10 to the power 10
to the power 50 was hardly close I don't
know he didn't give any working out for
this this was in passing I did say a lot
of these would be nonsense case let's
try some sensible estimate if it was
let's say if each player had an average
of three sensible moves instead of
thirty legal moves same sort of idea if
we did that was out of 30 to the power
18 it would be say 3 to the power 80
does that seem more reasonable yeah so
that's 3 to the power 80 I can tell you
that's roundabout 10 to the 450 so now
not as large as the number of atoms in
the observable universe still still very
large though 10 to the 40 if for example
everyone in the world paired off and
they had to play a game of chess every
day and it had to be a different game
every day and they did that to play all
possible games this 10 to the 40
sensible games it would still take you
trillions and trillions of years to play
them all or if you think about it
another way we consider all games of
chess that I've ever been played in
history then that is only a tiny
fraction of all the possible games of
chess there are to play I can't think of
a better supporter for a video about
chess than a company called Squarespace
now if you want a presence on the web
whether it's a blog a business or just a
cool way to tell the world about what
you're doing then Squarespace is a super
resource I host my own blog on
Squarespace and it's so quick and
hassle-free in a matter of minutes I can
have anything up on the way of looking
great
and that's looking great on both
computers and mobile devices which is
often the hard bit now whether you're a
bit of a novice or you are a coding
Grandmaster Squarespace will give you as
little or as much control as you like so
whatever your endgame you really should
check them out you see what I did there
check them out in-game that's pretty
good that anyway they've got a great
range of templates to get started then
you can tweak them play around until
your heart's content and I'm not just
saying this because they've sponsored
today's episode which they have and
thank you for that but I am a happy
customer now you can have a 14-day free
trial give it a go before you commit no
credit card required and then if you do
like them you can get 10% off your first
purchase go to squarespace.com slash
numberphile and thanks to Squarespace
for supporting this episode as they like
to say build it beautiful
do you play chess I do play chess
I know chess I know I'm no expert on
chess some no grandmaster I play chess
for fun perhaps is to play chess with my
dad